ja und wir bleiben bei Annalena baerbock
und auch ihr Verhältnis zur Robert
habecke das Dreamteam der Grünen man
muss sagen das war einmal ne ja die
beiden Minister sind sich laut Partei
Insidern gar nicht mehr so grün aus
doppelspielern sind erkennbar
Einzelkämpfer geworden und für die
Außenministerin läuft es momentan
deutlich besser als für robetik
vom Sunnyboy zum Prügelknaben das wirrwa
bei der gasumlage Bildungslücken bei den
AKWs und nicht zu vergessen seine irren
Energiespartipps der Wähler ist genervt
Robert Habeck stürzt in den Umfragen ab
gut wenn man in Krisenzeiten Freunde hat
davon hat Habeck in seiner Partei aber
offenbar nicht allzu viele Rückhalt
Fehlanzeige statt im öffentlich zur
Seite zu springen sagt Annalena baerbock
nichts Politik ist ein weinhartes
Geschäft da geht es vor allem um die
eigene Macht da gibt es keine
persönliche Rücksichtnahme auch nicht
bei den Grünen bärbock hat offenbar
nicht vergessen das Habeck sie 2021 in
ihrer Plagiatsaffäre hängen ließ und sie
nach der Bundestagswahl entmachtete
obwohl sie die Kanzlerkandidatin war
wurde er am Ende Vizekanzler inzwischen
ist bärbock die Nummer eins bei den
Wählern und sie strebt nach mehr für
einen mögliche Kanzlerkandidatur 2025
käme ihr also ein entzauberter Robert
Habeck Uhr nur recht und darüber wollen
wir jetzt sprechen mit Alexander throm
innenpolitischer Sprecher der CDU
schönen guten Tag Herr throm
ja guten Tag entscheidet sich die
Kandidatur für die kommende
Bundestagswahl also zwischen bärbock und
Harbeck
naja also jedenfalls tragen sie ihren
Streit ihren Wettkampf auf offener Bühne
aus und nachdem bärburg habe ich die
Kanzlerkandidatur letztes Jahr
weggenommen hat diese Kanzlerkandidatur
vergeigt hat ist es jetzt ein Stück weit
ja auch eine Retourkutsche habe Katja ja
auch dann eigentlich die
Vizekanzlerschaft die ihr Zustand dann
weggenommen und sie wie man so schön
sagt entmachtet insofern ja da streiten
zwei auf offener Bühne und wem das nicht
irgendwie auch die grüne Politik wenn
zwei so zentrale Figuren so gegenseitig
versuchen sich da den Rang abzulaufen
es ist es lemmt die gesamte
Bundesregierung so kann man ja insgesamt
nicht regieren wir haben eine
Bundesregierung aus drei Parteien und
diese drei Parteien das sehen wir jeden
Tag die streiten untereinander und jetzt
geht es auch noch innerhalb einer Partei
so dass man sich gegenseitig belauert
und das kann ich gut sein gerade in so
schwierigen Zeiten in dieser Krise
Außenpolitik
wirtschaftsenergiepolitik zentrale
Felder in diesen Zeiten da müsste man
sich mehr zusammenreißen auf die Sache
konzentrieren wegen den Bürgern und
Bürgern wegen der Sache wählen und nicht
jetzt schon die Kanzlerkandidatur für
die nächste Bundestagswahl wer von den
beiden wird sich letztlich durchsetzen
was meinen Sie
oder ist noch lang hin und ich befürchte
dass dieser Streit dieser Wettkampf den
wir da gerade erleben eben noch einige
Jahre so weitergehen wird ja man merkt
ja auch dass auch die Frau bärburg jetzt
offensichtlich wieder vorsichtiger wird
in ihren Äußerungen also da wird vieles
dieser möglichen Kanzlerkandidatur
untergeordnet das ist für die Sache und
für die Politik nicht gut
noch einmal auf Robert Habeck zu
sprechen kommen das war wie so ein Sony
Boy anfangs der Politik allen Start der
ins Auge jeder war überrascht von ihm
und jetzt jetzt hat er sich ziemlich ins
ausgeschossene rudert beispielsweise vor
sich hin wenn es darum geht zu erklären
was eine Insolvenz bedeutet glauben sie
da kommt er wieder raus glauben sie er
kann wieder dahin wo er mal war
na ja ich glaube er ist entzaubert und
man merkt dass er zwar schön
philosophieren kann man sagt ja so schön
man kann ihm bei denken zusehen oder
zuhören aber offensichtlich fehlt die
Substanz nicht nur bei dem Thema
Insolvenz sondern auch bei der gasumlage
war es morgens und der Vorschlag zum was
die den Weiterbetrieb der
Kernkraftwerke anbelangt ist ganz
offensichtlich nicht durchdacht und
schlicht ideologisch der eigenen
parteiline geschuldet aber auch hier
wieder nicht den Notwendigkeiten bei der
Energieversorgung für unser Land habe
gestern zaubert das sagt Alexander drum
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch danke
[Musik]